Teraz, gdy omówiliśmy wszystkie elementy VQE, podsumujmy
to, czego się nauczyliśmy, i zobaczmy, jak komputer kwantowy to wykonuje.
Zaczynamy od sprytnie dobranego stanu referencyjnego, sparametryzowanego circuit,
początkowego doboru parametrów i Hamiltonianu.
Przekazujemy to wszystko do naszego komputera kwantowego.
Zanim Hamiltonian będzie mógł zostać wykonany na stanie ansatz,
musimy przeprowadzić klasyczne wstępne przetwarzanie circuit
żeby był czytelny dla sprzętu kwantowego – w procesie zwanym transpilacją.
Ważne jest też, żeby jak najlepiej wykorzystać
architekturę qubitów w rzeczywistym sprzęcie, aby uzyskać najlepsze wyniki.
Te procesy są często obsługiwane automatycznie, dzięki czemu nie musimy
jawnie znać połączeń między qubitami,
wierności gate i tym podobnych.
Teraz zadaniem jest zmierzenie wynikowego stanu
i oszacowanie wartości oczekiwanej, która zostanie następnie
zoptymalizowana przez klasyczny optymalizator.
Ten pomiar jest wykonywany przez obrót bazy pomiarowej
a następnie połączenie wyników pomiarów w celu uzyskania wartości oczekiwanej.
Ten sparametryzowany wynik jest potem przekazywany
do klasycznego optymalizatora, który znajduje nowe parametry dla stanu.
Potem proces jest powtarzany.
Klasyczne wstępne przetwarzanie tworzy nowy sparametryzowany circuit
i stosujemy ten sam Hamiltonian co wcześniej.
Warto zaznaczyć, że w całym procesie VQE zmieniamy tylko stany
poprzez parametry, które zbliżają się coraz bardziej do stanu podstawowego.
Powtarzamy to, aż będziemy zadowoleni z wyniku.
I to tyle.
Nazywam się Victoria Lipinska i to był kurs variational quantum eigensolver.